on veut des explications là il faut
qu'on sache vraiment ce qui s'est passé
parce que là on est comme ça on n'en
peut plus et donc appelé didier finir
sur une plate forme chez allô allô allô
didier première sonnerie bonsoir c'est
la valise deuxième sonnerie attention ou
trois la vallée vous passionnez vieux et
nord peut-être bon on ne dort pas face à
va il y avait eu les batteurs 49 tort à
l'eau alors masqué rivier si vous le
regardez
[Applaudissements]
il se bat dinning dit il faut répondre
maintenant et vous avez payé la facture
ouais bah oui j'ai payé la facture à
l'eau didier hier soir c'est benjamin
castaldi dans touche pas à mon poste
avec lui comment ça vous dérange pas
écoutez je vous avais je suis d'abord je
veux dire que nous on vous adore et tous
m'ont des fans elle pouvait applaudir
des ide de savoir didier esquire on a
reçu fatima sur le plateau fatima a été
un peu triste que wave bomb à l'aiea les
parties faut appeler un chat un chat
elle s'est barrée et à l'isi que vous
avez à vous avez un peu manipulé moi je
voulais avoir votre votre version oui je
suis là oui alors je voulais savoir
qu'il était votre version alors la
version de quoi en fait
en fait fatima en fait fatima elle avait
l'impression que vous aviez pas ça de
jouer un peu avec elle est ce que vous
avez le sentiment d'avoir joué avec
fatima où est ce que finalement bas vous
préférez vous préférez l'autre
prétendante quoi il faut appeler un chat
un chat deuxième fois qu'est ce que je
dis à tout le temps comment en fait
c'est quoi c'est compliqué de faire un
choix en fait je veux dire
michel bigot d'accord d'accord mais je
comprends bien
[Applaudissements]
alors oui alors oui alors répondez par
oui ou par non
est ce que vous êtes conscient non c'est
pas des monnaies non non mais non mais
donc elle est ce que vous êtes heureux
dans le programme êtes de abba oui ça on
avoue profiter
vous profitez bien de du programme en
fait ça se passe bien vous êtes content
et est-ce que fatima vous manque un peu
à bourguiba baba cool pour moi c'est
clair bah ça s'est cabré maintenant vous
êtes joueur vous avez fait votre wii
[Applaudissements]
je connais la maison je la regarde bien
sûr on est on a mis à deux prétendantes
absolument ouais ouais bien sûr le voilà
c'est tout ça pas plus grave que ça vous
a fait un choix
alors alors j'ai une question très
importante parce que dans le programme
vous disais que vous étiez vous n'aviez
pas eu beaucoup de femmes doit avoir
zéro et est-ce que ça va mieux
maintenant voulait plus assez de secours
si vous êtes plus haut
écoutez jb j'espère que vous viendrez
voir bas sur le plateau ce qu'il vous
invitez et si vous avez eu un petit mot
sympa pour fatima
ce serait cool vous nous le dites et moi
je devrais passer exactement
[Applaudissements]
évidemment j'ai tout compris
la morale de l'histoire
l'amour est dans le pré me l'a très bien
merci